so when you go to Sweden people walk
into stores like this and they get a bag
and they take all this candy and they
just put it all in the same bag and it
ends up looking like this it's just like
tons of different candy and a lot of
that candy is licorice type stuff it's
like salty licorice with sweet this
isn't just sweet and this is like all
over Scandinavia they love salty sweet
grab bags of candy and it's kind of
chaotic but it's kind of amazing I'm
thinking about this right now because
our studio manager Nick brought this
stuff back from Iceland which is
chocolate that is surrounding Licorice
and I have eaten 17 of these things per
day maybe per hour for the last three
weeks that's where they're almost at
[Applause]